hasta ahora china ha sido cuidadosa y no
ha dado apoyo material directo a Rusia
para usar contra Ucrania pero a Estados
Unidos le preocupa que eso pueda estar a
punto de cambiar un día después de
reunirse con su homólogo chino el
secretario de estado estadounidense
reiteró su advertencia
habría consecuencias reales en nuestra
propia relación con chinas y
proporcionar ayuda letal a Rusia en esta
agresión contra Ucrania
tenemos una preocupación real de que
china esté considerando hacer
precisamente eso en plena escalada de
tensiones entre Estados Unidos y China
por los globos espía la respuesta de
China fue contundente dijo a Washington
que no se meta en su relación con Rusia
es Estados Unidos quien sigue
suministrando armas al campo de batalla
no china Estados Unidos no está en
posición de decirnos lo que tenemos que
hacer y nunca aceptaremos que nos señale
con el dedo e incluso que nos coaccione
y presione en las relaciones entre China
y Rusia el principio que china sigue en
la cuestión ucraniana puede expresarse
Sencillamente como la promoción de
conversaciones de paz
el Ministerio de asuntos exteriores de
China dice que dejara Clara su posición
sobre una solución política de la guerra
tras la visita de su máximo diplomático
a Moscú el kremlin calificó la agenda de
la visita como muy amplia y con mucho
que discutir Beijing y Moscú también han
ampliado sus lazos amilitares con una
serie de ejercicios conjuntos pero su
amistad sin límites no ha llegado al
punto de armar a Rusia el lunes el
presidente zelensky advirtió a China que
de hacerlo provocaría una guerra mundial